J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour à vous et bienvenue pour un nouvel épisode de Septante Minutes Avec, dernier épisode de la saison.
Peut-être que vous êtes déjà très loin et que vous m'écoutez depuis l'autre bout du monde puisque, en effet, on est déjà mi-juillet.
Et comme vous avez pu le voir, j'ai accumulé énormément de retard dans la sortie des épisodes. À nouveau, je suis désolé pour ça, mais bon, mieux vaut tard que jamais.
Et la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'on se quitte en beauté avec un très chouette épisode où je suis accompagné de Pierre Oswald, psychiatre et médecin chef au Centre hospitalier Jean Titeca, ici à Bruxelles,
pour parler ensemble de paraphilie, de troubles paraphiliques.
Donc autrement dit, on va parler de pratiques sexuelles entre guillemets déviantes. Pensez donc à éloigner les enfants.
Bonne écoute. Mais j'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Pierre Oswald. Bonjour Pierre.
Bonjour.
Et d'ailleurs, j'ai pas posé la question, comment est-ce que vous souhaitez être présenté ?
Je dirais d'abord que je suis le directeur médical d'un hôpital psychiatrique.
Ah ouais.
Là où on se trouve actuellement, c'est le Centre hospitalier Jean Titeca.
C'est un hôpital psychiatrique qui se trouve à Schaerbeek, à Bruxelles, qui accueille à peu près deux cent cinquante patients et qui a une fonction prioritaire de faire de la psychiatrie médico-légale.
C'est ça.
Et donc, la psychiatrie médico-légale peut se résumer à dire comment on prend en charge le mieux possible des personnes qui sont là contre leur volonté.
Donc, c'est des soins sous contrainte.
Mh. Donc une section bien particulière de la, la psychiatrie du coup. Et vous avez l'occasion d'explorer tous ces sujets dans votre podcast puisque en plus de cette belle casquette de directeur médical, vous êtes aussi podcasteur vous-même.
C'est pas comme ça que je vous avais choisi à la base, mais c'était une heureuse surprise de voir que j'allais rencontrer un confrère podcasteur.
Et pas concurrent, hein. Pas concurrent, mais du tout. Oui, effectivement, on a, avec Alban Antoine, le directeur général, justement, d'ici du Centre hospitalier Jean Titeca, initié des podcasts.
Ça va bientôt faire un an. On en a fait une bonne dizaine maintenant qui couvrent tous les sujets de la santé mentale. Et donc, n'hésitez pas à aller écouter Psyké.
Sur toutes les plateformes, ils sont disponibles.
Voilà. Vous avez la formation du bon promoteur de podcast.
Merci pour la pub.
Donc oui, et donc dans Psyké, justement, vous avez l'occasion d'aborder,
voilà, différents aspects également de la psychiatrie, mais pas forcément ce que vous rencontrez ici, j'imagine, puisque voilà, il est question par exemple de TDAH, de dépression.
Ici, vous parlez de, donc, psychiatrie sous contrainte, donc c'est un autre type de public. Et plus particulièrement, la raison pour laquelle je vous ai invité dans Septante Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, c'est pour parler la question des paraphilies.
Comment est-ce qu'on pourrait définir ça ? Je pense que dans l'inconscient, dans l'imaginaire collectif, il s'agit de pathologies en termes de préférences sexuelles.
Comment est-ce que vous décririez ça ?
Alors, je vais peut-être répondre déjà en essayant de, si vous voulez bien, de vous corriger puisque pathologie, déjà, c'est un mot qu'on ne va pas tellement utiliser pour les paraphilies.
Alors, je vais essayer de m'expliquer. Alors, si on devait parler d'une définition des paraphilies, on pourrait dire que c'est un comportement sexuel déviant par rapport aux normes, je dirais, acceptables dans une société ou à une époque donnée.
Donc déjà, dans cette réponse, c'est très construit. On pourrait être catégorisé comme ayant une paraphilie dans un contexte et pas du tout dans un autre contexte.
Ah tout à fait. À certaines époques, certains comportements sexuels qu'on considère comme déviants actuellement ne l'étaient pas.
Et tout comme on peut tout à fait imaginer que dans certains pays du monde, certains comportements ne sont pas considérés comme déviants.
Donc c'est une notion éminemment culturelle.
Alors, il y a un autre aspect qui est essentiel et c'est pour ça que je parlais de remettre en question la notion de pathologie,
c'est que dans nos classifications psychiatriques, hein, je vais pas rentrer dans le détail, mais dans nos classifications psychiatriques,
on fait une différence importante entre ce qui est observable et ce qui crée de la
souffrance, ce qui crée une dysfonction, ce qui crée des difficultés.
Et donc, dans les paraphilies, on va faire la distinction entre ce que l'on appelle les paraphilies simples, entre guillemets, qui nécessitent d'être évaluées, mais on peut en rester là, et ce qu'on appelle des troubles paraphiliques.
Et les troubles paraphiliques se différencient des paraphilies par le fait qu'ils présentent des dysfonctions qui créent de la souffrance ou parfois qui créent des victimes.
Et donc là, ce sont des troubles en tant que tels qui nécessitent une intervention pour à la fois diminuer la situation de détresse que peut présenter la personne qui a le trouble paraphilique ou bien pour qu'il y ait moins de victimes.
Et donc le terme trouble vient afficher une notion de détresse.
Détresse, exactement. Et donc c'est ce qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans toute la nosographie, c'est-à-dire la classification des maladies mentales.
On ne parle de troubles que quand il y a vraiment détresse.
Mh. Et donc pour être concret, l'espace d'un instant, les personnes concernées par les paraphilies, mais qui ne sont pas dans une situation de trouble, on penserait à quoi alors ?
C'est une très très bonne question et—
Je suis là pour ça.
On rentre tout de suite dans le vif du sujet. Alors, il y a un sujet qui a fait beaucoup débat dans l'élaboration de ces hypothèses-là.
Ce sont ceux qui pratiquent le bondage et ceux qui sont fans de BDSM.
C'est ça, OK.
Alors, il est évident qu'à partir du moment où c'est quelque chose qui est accepté par tous ceux qui—
Mh, consentis
...qui consentent effectivement à participer à ça, il y a aucun souci. Il y a néanmoins toujours un petit peu une frontière entre ce qu'on appelle le masochisme ou le sadisme.
Mais effectivement, à partir du moment où c'est consenti, il n'y a pas de souci. Il s'agit néanmoins de dire que selon, vraiment, si on consulte les,
les, les classifications internationales, les personnes qui pratiquent le BDSM présentent une paraphilie, mais ne présentent pas de trouble paraphilique puisqu'il n'y a pas de détresse exprimée ou de détresse observable.
Donc, est-ce qu'il y a un seuil statistique à partir duquel il faut être en dessous pour que ce soit catégorisé comme étant marginal, comme étant un peu hors norme ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est vraiment une question de perception très située ?
Un peu des deux. Il y a la question qui a beaucoup animé tous les chercheurs dans ce domaine-là, c'était de savoir si une paraphilie ou un trouble paraphilique est quelque chose qui représente une catégorie finie,
on l'est ou on l'est pas, ou bien s'il s'agit d'une,
d'un aspect dimensionnel, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un spectre,
et là, le seuil serait celui de la détresse, mais qui est alors là une situation éminemment subjective.
Et j'ai même une petite réponse à vous apporter là-dessus. On a pu démontrer à travers pas mal de travaux que les troubles paraphiliques sont un petit peu à l'extrême d'un spectre dimensionnel qu'à la limite, on partage tous.
On a tous un petit côté sadique, on a tous un petit côté maso, on a tous un petit côté voyeur ou un petit côté exhibitionniste.
Alors évidemment, on n'est pas tous pour autant porteur d'un trouble paraphilique. On devient porteur d'un trouble paraphilique, comme je le disais, qu'à partir du seuil où il y a souffrance d'un tiers ou détresse personnelle.
Mais donc, votre réponse à la question des exemples de personnes concernées par la paraphilie, mais où ça n'est pas un cas de détresse, un cas de trouble paraphilique, ce serait alors un peu tout le monde ?
Oui, je pense que ça pourrait être un peu tout le monde et ça pointe un petit peu un des aspects un peu parfois négatifs de la psychiatrie qui, parce qu'elle veut bien faire, a tendance un peu à catégoriser tout le monde, hein.
Et c'est un petit peu ce qu'on vit actuellement où, dès qu'il y a un comportement qui est un petit peu différent de la norme, ben on a tendance à le psychiatriser.
Et donc le rôle des psychiatres là-dedans est justement d'essayer le plus possible d'éviter de réduire une personne à un diagnostic ou à un trait de personnalité.
Mais il y a toute une série de comportements, y compris les comportements sexuels, qui sont de l'ordre à la fois du privé, ça, c'est évident,
mais qui sont de l'ordre aussi de décisions personnelles et la psychiatrie n'a rien à voir là-dedans.
Mmm mmm. La psychiatrie a longtemps été critiquée pour son côté très normalisateur. Dès qu'on trouve des personnes hors norme, on va
essayer de les forcer dans une certaine norme sociale, on va essayer de les forcer dans une norme, même quand il s'agit de, voilà,
s'il ne s'agit pas de pathologie, mais même quand il s'agit de pathologie, il s'agit de vraiment
guérir de force, normaliser, chercher à tout prix la norme.
Donc, vous dites qu'aujourd'hui, on s'éloigne de plus en plus de ça, c'est, c'est... Je comprends.
Oui, oui, c'est— là aussi, c'est un vrai débat avec parfois, on avance d'un pas et on recule d'un pas.
La question de la psychiatrie par rapport à la société, son côté normatif, ça fait aussi l'objet de vastes discussions.
Il faut savoir deux, trois petites choses. La première chose, c'est que la psychiatrie n'est jamais à l'avant-garde.
La psychiatrie a souvent cette tendance à suivre un petit peu les évolutions de la société. Il ne faut pas espérer que la psychiatrie soit vraiment à l'avant-garde de conceptions sociales ou psychologiques.
Et l'autre chose, c'est qu'il faut toujours, et ça, c'est un élément essentiel que nous devons garder en tête, nous, psychiatres, c'est qu'on a tendance à nous conférer
un pouvoir dans la société qui est d'expliquer de manière rationnelle tous des aspects irrationnels.
Pourquoi on fait du mal à des gens ? Pourquoi on tient des propos un peu bizarroïdes ? Eh bien,
dans la recherche, un peu dans la quête éperdue qu'on a tous de savoir pourquoi on en arrive à parfois commettre des comportements complètement incroyables, eh bien, on fait un peu appel au psychiatre
qui, lui, va un peu tendance à réduire la personne, peut-être, à une pathologie, un trouble.
Et donc là, c'est un piège dans lequel il faut surtout éviter de tomber puisque le psychiatre ne peut pas donner des causes, ne peut pas expliquer tous les comportements.
Il— ce n'est qu'une discipline médicale qui peut reconnaître à certains égards ou dans certaines situations, des troubles psychiatriques.
Je suis impressionné par l'art, l'habileté avec laquelle vous arrivez à exprimer tout ça. On voit que vous êtes habitué aux présentations et aux podcasts.
Oui, c'est encore une occasion supplémentaire d'écouter Psyké, effectivement.
On va essayer de le placer le plus souvent dans le cadre de cette interview. Voilà, on a bien précisé qu'effectivement, la question des paraphilies, voilà, relativement un petit peu tout le monde, comme vous le disiez.
On va peut-être, dans le cadre de cet échange, s'adresser en particulier aux cas les plus remarquables, disons, notamment la question de troubles paraphiliques.
Donc, vous citiez l'exemple du bondage qui n'était pas un trouble paraphilique puisqu'effectivement, là, a priori, les gens sont plutôt consentants et sont bien dans leur peau à ce niveau-là.
Des exemples alors intéressants de troubles paraphiliques, des exemples plus remarquables.
Alors, ben, je vais être très didactique, peut-être, comme j'essaie de l'être apparemment depuis le début de l'émission.
C'est que les classifications internationales décrivent un certain nombre de troubles paraphiliques qui,
parce qu'ils ont fait l'objet d'études un peu plus fouillées, sont considérés comme à peu près tous les experts comme étant des troubles paraphiliques en tant que tels.
Alors, on peut les passer tous en revue, mais je citerais peut-être deux troubles paraphiliques qui sont peut-être plus fréquents.
Alors, je vais même en citer trois. Le premier, c'est évidemment la pédophilie, avec le trouble pédophilique, qui est peut-être le trouble paraphilique dont on parle le plus actuellement.
On a parlé de bondage. Dans certains cas, le sadisme sexuel est un trouble en tant que tel puisqu'il y a—
ça génère une vraie excitation sexuelle de la part de l'auteur et puis alors une détresse importante, parfois chez l'auteur, il faut le reconnaître, mais surtout chez la victime.
Et puis alors, il y a aussi des choses dont on a l'impression qu'il s'agit finalement de choses assez drôles ou assez anecdotiques, mais ça peut à la fois provoquer des traumas et dans un deuxième temps,
c'est fréquent, ce sont les notions d'exhibitionnisme et de voyeurisme.
Ah oui, OK. Et donc, est-ce que vous, dans le cadre de votre pratique, vous avez l'occasion de rencontrer des personnes concernées par ces trois grandes familles de troubles paraphiliques ?
Ben oui, ça a été une grande partie de mon activité clinique pendant pas mal d'années. Donc avant que j'atterrisse ici,
au Centre hospitalier Jean Titeca, puisque je travaillais avant dans un hôpital psychiatrique sécurisé qui accueillait des personnes ayant commis en tout cas des infractions à caractère sexuel.
Et dans cette population d'agresseurs sexuels, ben une partie présente un trouble paraphilique.
Ça me permet peut-être de dire, je sais pas si on peut déjà dévoiler cet aspect-là des choses, mais ce n'est qu'une part assez minoritaire des agresseurs sexuels qui présentent un vrai trouble paraphilique.
Ah oui.
Hein, il y a des agressions sexuelles qui sont commises par des personnes qui, pour des raisons tout à fait variables, variées, agressent sexuellement une autre personne sans pour autant présenter un trouble paraphilique.
Mais n'empêche néanmoins que dans le cadre de cette population d'agresseurs sexuels, une minorité d'entre eux, ça fait quand même vingt, trente pour cent d'entre eux, présentent un trouble paraphilique bien constitué.
Et en effet, bah la majorité d'entre eux,
puisque je les ai vus sous contrainte, c'étaient des pédophiles, mais j'ai aussi rencontré des exhibitionnistes, des voyeuristes, des sadiques, des masochistes, sans pour autant que toutes ces distinctions
s'annulent, hein.
Il y en a certains qui même les cumulent.
Mais c'est intéressant parce qu'effectivement, j'ai l'impression que quand il s'agit de commenter un fait d'actualité sur une personne qui aurait par exemple commis un,
un acte à caractère pédophile, j'ai l'impression qu'effectivement, rapidement, la question du,
la pathologie, la question du diagnostic, la question du, cette personne a un problème, cette personne...
La question de la psychiatrisation des agresseurs est assez systématique.
Oui.
Et on a plus envie de retomber là-dessus pour expliquer quelque chose d'assez inexplicable autrement, finalement.
C'est vrai. Et c'est vrai. Et si je peux me permettre de rajouter une petite difficulté supplémentaire à cette discussion,
c'est qu'en effet, j'ai dit, et je vous rejoins tout à fait, on doit vraiment être très vigilant quant à la psychiatrisation des choses.
Mais je rajouterais qu'à défaut d'autres possibilités, la psychiatrie et plus globalement la psychologie légale amènent un certain nombre de réponses pour, par exemple, limiter la récidive.
Que ce soit des personnes qui présentent un trouble paraphilique comme une pédophilie bien constituée
ou bien des personnes qui sont des agresseurs sexuels
sans, qui ne présentent pas de trouble paraphilique, eh bien, on a pu démontrer que travailler avec eux la prévention de la récidive selon un mode psychologique ou psychiatrique, va diminuer aussi la récidive.
Donc on a quand même un certain nombre d'outils qui s'adressent à la fois à ceux qui présentent un trouble bien constitué, mais aussi à des personnes qui ont agressé sexuellement.
Et l'objectif alors d'une peine est non seulement de les punir, hein, ça, c'est, mais aussi de limiter le risque qu'ils recommencent.
Et donc là, les psychologues et certains psychiatres peuvent apporter certains outils.
Et donc le caractère de trouble paraphilique pour, vous disiez vingt à trente pour cent des—
Des agresseurs sexuels.
Des agresseurs sexuels, oui. Comment est-ce qu'on explique alors les autres ? Vous disiez une variété de raisons, différentes raisons qui peuvent amener une personne à commettre ce type d'agression.
Là aussi, il y a parfois des raisons qu'on ne connaît pas, des raisons inexplicables. Je vais prendre l'exemple du viol.
Je prends cet exemple-là parce que, lors de l'élaboration de ces fameuses classifications de paraphilie, certains ont proposé que le viol soit pathologisé et donc que le viol coercitif répété soit considéré comme une maladie mentale.
Ah, c'est intéressant parce que vous faisiez la séparation entre paraphilie et pathologie. Et maintenant, vous expliquez que certains ont proposé l'idée de pathologiser la volonté d'être un violent.
Oui, tout à fait. Et donc, vous voyez, tout ça est compliqué et que le viol répété, coercitif évidemment par essence, pourrait être un trouble paraphilique en tant que tel.
Et là, finalement, ça n'a pas été repris par manque de données scientifiques, mais on voit tout de suite le débat éthique qu'il y a là derrière.
Parce que si on considère que c'est un trouble, d'une certaine manière, ça dédouane les auteurs des actes en disant : « Bah voilà, c'est une maladie, donc... »
Expliquer n'est pas excuser, mais effectivement, on a tendance à peut-être un peu, mmm, être moins dur avec quelqu'un quand une explication est présente.
Exactement. Alors, c'est tout le débat actuel, c'est de voir quelle est la place de la responsabilité individuelle dans la commission d'actes.
Et effectivement, comme vous venez de le dire, une partie de la responsabilité individuelle peut être limitée, voire, la responsabilité peut être abolie du fait de l'existence d'une maladie psychiatrique.
Alors, je vais prendre un exemple, deux exemples très opposés. Une personne qui présente une schizophrénie, une psychose vraiment avérée avec un délire, peut par exemple agresser sexuellement quelqu'un.
Parce que des voix dans sa tête lui ont dit de le faire.
Ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui présente un trouble paraphilique, mais néanmoins, il y a un trouble psychiatrique derrière qui va faire que cette personne ne sera pas responsable de ses actes.
Et puis, d'un autre côté, il y a une personne bien dans sa tête, enfin, qui pense l'être, qui a les pieds sur terre, qui ne consomme pas spécialement de substances et qui décide un beau matin d'agresser une jeune femme dans la rue.
C'est tout à fait possible, sans pour autant que derrière ça, il y ait un quelconque trouble paraphilique, puisque dans ses antécédents, dans sa fantasmatique,
on ne trouve rien qui peut dénoter, par exemple, d'un plaisir sadique ou d'un plaisir masochiste, etc.
Même dans le cas de la personne schizophrène, il n'est pas évident que ce soit un facteur dans son choix de passer à l'acte.
Et plein de personnes schizophrènes qui vivent tout à fait en paix...
Ah tout à fait. Et d'ailleurs, l'immense majorité de ces personnes vivent en paix et en plus avec un risque quasi nul de commettre des agressions sexuelles.
C'est aussi des chiffres qu'on a. Les personnes qui sont porteuses d'une psychose, même en phase active, ne commettent très peu d'agressions sexuelles.
Mais vous prenez cet exemple pour montrer quelque part la question de la perception et les biais qu'on peut avoir vis-à-vis de ces questions-là.
Exactement.
Et donc j'essaie de retomber sur ma question à l'origine qui était... Oui, donc je parlais des soixante, septante pour cent de personnes qui passent à l'acte sans être concernées par une paraphilie.
Mais donc, voilà, l'exemple du viol est particulier puisque là, effectivement, vous disiez, ça n'a pas été retenu comme étant un trouble paraphilique.
Mais donc si on prend l'exemple le plus connu, celui qui est le plus mis en avant et dont on parle, voilà, d'une agression sexuelle, d'un viol sur une personne mineure.
Qu'est-ce qui... On va évidemment se concentrer sur les personnes concernées par les paraphilies, mais qu'est-ce qui peut amener une personne qui n'est pas concernée par les paraphilies, qui n'a pas un diagnostic à ce niveau-là,
de commettre ce genre d'acte si ça n'est pas une particularité au niveau de sa psyché ?
Oui donc, on parle vraiment de personnes ici qui n'ont pas de fantasmes spécifiquement orientés ou de besoins sexuels tellement envahissants qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'empêcher d'agresser.
Là, il y a quand même, là aussi, toute une série d'études, des observations qui montrent que le passage à l'acte sexuel, même sur mineur, n'est pas spécifiquement associé à des éléments médicaux ou psychiatriques de ce type-là.
Il peut y avoir, par exemple, une difficulté d'intérioriser la loi. Je peux vraiment vous assurer que j'ai rencontré des personnes qui ne savaient pas qu'elles ne pouvaient pas agresser des mineurs.
Ce sont des personnes qui, soit socialement, familialement ou parce qu'elles n'ont pas les compétences intellectuelles, n'ont pas intériorisé cet interdit. Donc, ça existe.
Il y a la prise de toute une série de substances qui désinhibe. L'alcool, évidemment, loin devant,
peut entraîner la commission d'actes de ce type-là, sans pour autant que la personne exprime une fantasmatique à orientation pédophilique.
Mais donc, dans les différents cas que vous citez, c'est toujours un contexte bien particulier, donc avec des compétences intellectuelles en retrait, pour dire ça comme ça, ou bien des substances qui ont été consommées.
Mais donc une personne sobre, en capacité intellectuelle de réfléchir à ce qu'il est en train de faire, ça arrive aussi ?
Ben oui. Oui, et parce que je pense qu'on a tous et c'est heureux dans l'immense majorité des cas, la capacité de décider.
Mmm-hmm.
Et rappelez-vous un peu ce qu'on disait en début d'émission, la différence entre une paraphilie et un trouble paraphilique.
Quand on évoque la pédophilie en tant que paraphilie, on pense à toutes ces personnes qui ont des fantasmes orientés vers les enfants.
On parle de ces personnes qui ont des fantasmes pédophiliques et qui, de temps en temps, vont jeter un œil sur des,
sur des photos pornographiques ou sur des films pornographiques qui mettent en scène des, peut-être pas des enfants, mais des jeunes garçons, des jeunes filles qui sont à la limite de la puberté.
Enfin... donc ce que je veux dire derrière ça, c'est que l'immense majorité des personnes qui ont des fantasmes d'orientation pédophilique ne passent pas à l'acte, gardent ça pour eux.
C'est souvent une souffrance, c'est souvent une fragilité qui les met dans des situations difficiles. Mais il y a cette contrainte sociale, heureuse.
Il y a la peur du gendarme. Il y a toute une série de craintes ou de morale qui font que ces gens ne passent pas à l'acte.
Et vous appelez ça comment ? Des personnes qui ont un attrait pour des contenus pédophiles ?
Oui.
Vous appelez ça comme ça ?
Oui, on peut appeler comme ça ou un intérêt ou une... oui, qui sont orientés vers ce type de contenu, ça existe.
Alors maintenant, d'ailleurs, le nouveau code pénal définit que la consultation d'images à caractère pédopornographique est en soi un délit.
Donc, ça met déjà la barre un petit peu plus loin.
Mais, au travers de ça, je veux vraiment insister sur le fait qu'il y a une grande différence à effectuer entre ceux qui pensent à faire des choses, qui nourrissent leur fantasme de ça, et ceux qui passent à l'acte.
Et il n'y a pas de lien évident entre le fait de mûrir une fantasmatique pédophile et le passage à l'acte. Tout est possible.
Il y a des personnes qui développent une fantasmatique assez impressionnante autour de fantasmes déviants d'allure pédophilique, mais qui ne passent jamais à l'acte.
Et puis alors, on a des gens qui jamais n'ont nourri une fantasmatique pédophilique et qui,
là aussi, pour des raisons que j'ai un petit peu évoquées, passent à l'acte sans pour autant, ni avant ni après, avoir la moindre envie de nourrir leur fantasmatique de relations sexuelles avec des enfants.
Et donc, vous expliquez qu'il n'y a pas de rapport, de lien de cause à effet entre ce genre de fantasmes, ce genre d'attraits ?
Je vous coupe, désolé, mais il y a quand même un petit fil rouge. Et il faut bien reconnaître que dans la plupart des cas,
les personnes qui passent à l'acte sur des enfants dans le cadre d'un trouble pédophilique ont quand même nourri leur fantasmatique au travers, par exemple, de la consultation d'images pédopornographiques.
Donc il y a quand même des étapes qui sont en général présentes. Ce sur quoi je voulais insister, c'était que ces étapes ne sont pas toutes systématiques, naturelles et que, voilà, chaque cas étant différent, on peut avoir de tout.
Il n'y a pas d'équivalence entre quelqu'un qui consommerait, qui aurait ce genre de fantasmes et quelqu'un qui passe à l'action.
Oui, quand même. Alors, je vais tout petit peu nuancer. C'est que c'est une question qui fait l'objet de recherches encore actuellement.
Les experts s'entretuent là-dessus. Donc est-ce que la consultation d'images pédopornographiques pousse à l'acte pédocriminel ou pas ?
Est-ce que ça les apaise de regarder certaines vidéos ou de regarder certaines images ? Là, pour le moment, les études vont dans tous les sens.
Donc, on ne sait pas encore réellement répondre à cette question. Ce qu'on peut faire, c'est quand même observer qu'une majorité, je dis bien une majorité de personnes qui présentent un trouble paraphilique
pédophilique, sont quand même passées par la phase de consultation d'images.
Petite question très accessoire, mais ce genre d'études, il y a une difficulté à les mener.
Ah oui, ça c'est très compliqué.
Oui, puisqu'on peut difficilement exposer des personnes à ce genre de contenu tout en respectant la loi.
Oui, ben, ça aussi, vous vous appuyez sur un élément qui est essentiel dans notre domaine, c'est qu'on manque vraiment beaucoup d'études.
Alors, effectivement, on ne va pas lancer des études qu'on appelle prospectives, c'est-à-dire mettre les personnes en situation et les observer.
Alors, on a certains échappatoires. Le premier, c'est de faire des études rétrospectives. Donc, c'est-à-dire qu'on interroge beaucoup les personnes qui ont commis des délits de ce type-là et on,
et on essaie de comprendre leur parcours et ça fait l'objet de multiples études.
Et puis alors, il y a aussi maintenant l'utilisation de l'intelligence artificielle, l'utilisation d'avatars aussi sur écran.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut exposer des personnes qui présentent un trouble paraphilique à des avatars d'enfants qui sont dénudés, par exemple.
C'est assez étonnant, mais ça se fait.
Générés par intelligence artificielle.
Oui, tout à fait.
Donc, on se dit qu'éthiquement... Mais déjà, pour que ces algorithmes puissent générer ce genre d'images, il faut qu'elles aient été exposées à...
Oui.
De toute façon à un dataset sur lequel s'entraîner, non ?
Exactement. Et ça, c'est un sujet qui est particulièrement discuté en Europe.
Utiliser ce genre d'outils type intelligence artificielle qui doit lui-même s'entraîner sur...
Exactement.
Du contenu existant.
Par contre, au Canada ou aux États-Unis, il y a un peu moins de freins à ce type d'usage où les études
qui vont dans ce sens-là, c'est-à-dire des études d'exposition à des images générées par l'intelligence artificielle, ce genre d'études est mené,
je dirais pas facilement, évidemment, mais quand même fait un peu plus fréquemment que chez nous, en Europe.
C'est marrant parce que j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui date de douze, vingt-quatre derniers mois et vous en parlez déjà comme si c'est quelque chose, oui, qu'on a déjà eu l'occasion de voir à plusieurs reprises.
Ah oui. Alors l'intelligence artificielle est effectivement intervenue plus récemment, mais j'ai toujours en tête,
il y a quelques années, une équipe canadienne qui était venue nous présenter des avatars de jeunes enfants nus pour pouvoir travailler avec nos délinquants sexuels.
Des avatars, donc, générés, quoi, en 3D comme en jeu vidéo ou pas ?
C'est généré en 3D par jeu vidéo et...
Ah d'accord, ok.
Mais ces avatars étaient effectivement... commençaient à être réalistes d'ailleurs. Et ça créait un certain trouble dans ceux qui les regardaient.
Moi y compris, je trouvais ça quelque peu malsain. Depuis lors, les avatars se sont évidemment améliorés, développés.
Et là où on pouvait vraiment faire la différence avec une situation réelle, c'est évident, petit à petit, on se rapproche de situations réelles.
Alors, je sais que je digresse à chaque question que je pose, mais est-ce que quand vous dites ça, en fait, ça donne l'impression...
Je vais vous poser la question directement, en fait. Est-ce que dans le cadre de votre travail, vous êtes amené à être exposé à ce genre de contenu ?
Moi, oui, j'ai longtemps eu une activité d'expert auprès des tribunaux, donc j'étais chargé d'évaluer
des personnes inculpées ou après une décision de justice qui présentaient un trouble paraphilique.
Et ça m'a amené à consulter des éléments de dossier avec parfois des images particulièrement impressionnantes, voire odieuses, oui.
Mh, mh. Bon ok. Donc, pour remonter différentes questions que j'ai posées, on évoquait donc le caractère des personnes qui ont peut-être un attrait vers ce type de contenu, mais qui ne passent pas forcément à l'acte.
Cet attrait, comment est-ce qu'il se développe ? Quelle est l'origine story de personnes qui ont ce genre, oui, d'attrait ?
Ma réponse, elle sera à la fois simple et compliquée. Il faut qu'on pense chacun à notre propre sexualité et comment elle s'est développée.
Mh.
Je pense que les sexualités qu'on appelle déviantes, sources de paraphilie ou troubles paraphiliques, se développent exactement comme nos sexualités qu'on a souvent tendance à considérer comme normales, puisque c'est nous qui vivons avec.
J'ai toujours été très frappé quand je discutais avec ces personnes qui présentaient, selon moi, un trouble paraphilique, c'est qu'ils avaient une conviction que leur sexualité était tout à fait normale.
Légitime.
Légitime, oui. Se rendaient bien compte à certains moments, pour la plupart d'entre eux, qu'ils avaient transgressé la loi.
Donc, passe à l'acte.
Oui, effectivement, dans ces cas-là, tout est bien que...
Parce que là, il y a la notion de consentement qui, là, est très objectivement, très factuellement, oubliée ou annulée.
Le consentement, c'est un élément essentiel dont on va peut-être pouvoir parler parce que c'est effectivement à travers le consentement qu'on peut travailler avec eux.
Mais au-delà du consentement, l'attirance qu'ils expriment pour telle ou telle personne, telle ou telle pratique, tel ou tel objet, parce qu'on n'a pas parlé du fétichisme, par exemple, mais le fétichisme est aussi considéré comme une paraphilie,
eh bien, c'est pour eux le même développement.
On peut imaginer comme étant en partie génétique, en partie environnementale, bref, une construction complexe d'un rapport à l'autre ou d'un rapport à l'environnement qui définit nos propres sexualités et qui définissent aussi la leur.
Donc, dans la construction, je pense que c'est un modèle qui, globalement, il y a toujours des exceptions, bien sûr, qui globalement, est un modèle de développement assez normal, je dirais, du développement d'une sexualité.
Alors, à ça, je vais quand même ajouter deux, trois points.
Certains auteurs et certains psychanalystes nous disent : « Ok, il y a peut-être un développement qu'ils considèrent comme normal, mais nous, nous considérons qu'il y a des stades de développement auxquels ces personnes se sont arrêtées.
» Puisque selon certaines théories, on passe finalement par un certain nombre de stades un peu sadiques, un peu maso. Quand on est un jeune adolescent, on a tendance à être un peu voyeuriste.
Et donc, ce que nous disent certains auteurs, c'est qu'au-delà du développement en tant que tel, il y a peut-être des arrêts qui ont été un peu prolongés chez ces gens.
Vous avez prononcé le mot psychanalyse. Directement, moi, je me fais demander si ce genre de conclusion est très scientifique ou si c'est avant tout une thèse.
C'est une thèse, mais qu'il faut tout à fait considérer avec beaucoup, beaucoup d'intérêt.
On peut poser la question. Maintenant, est-ce que ça a été vérifié ? Est-ce que c'est...
Non, non, ça n'a pas été vérifié, en particulier parce que la psychanalyse, en tout cas, on va parler de la psychanalyse la plus classique, se prête peu à une méthodologie scientifique.
C'est clair.
Et la deuxième chose
quand même à dire, je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et donc il faut regarder d'abord dans son assiette, c'est que
ceux qui ne sont pas psychanalystes et qui évoquent ces sujets-là n'ont pas non plus énormément d'études scientifiques à se mettre sous la dent.
Donc, on est quand même dans un domaine où toute bonne volonté est bonne à prendre et que toute théorie peut être réfléchie et peut être investiguée.
Et donc c'est pour ça que, et je le dis souvent, sans être psychanalyste, c'est que ce sont quand même les psychanalystes qui nous ont permis pendant longtemps de penser la sexualité et que le rapport, il est inestimable.
Ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il est unique, qu'il est univoque, mais il est très très important. Et donc il y a à la fois, je le disais, certaines personnes qui s'arrêteraient à un certain stade de développement.
Et puis alors, il y a aussi l'hypothèse dont on parle beaucoup actuellement, c'est l'hypothèse du traumatisme.
C'est que certains traumas peuvent fixer certaines personnes à certains stades du développement ou à certaines situations, certains comportements qui les pousseraient peut-être vers certaines situations déviantes.
Ça, c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'on entend beaucoup. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous constatez, que vous remarquez au contact de patients ?
Oui, oui. Alors avec peut-être un point de vue qui est un peu biaisé puisque je les rencontre une fois qu'ils ont été reconnus soit coupables, soit irresponsables.
Donc quand il y a eu une décision de justice, donc je vois ceux qui se sont fait prendre et peut-être un milieu sociologique particulier.
Et là aussi, sans me cacher derrière des études, mais là aussi, la plupart des études montrent que la plupart des personnes qui passent à l'acte sexuellement, qui sont des agresseurs sexuels, ont vécu,
plus fréquemment que d'autres, des épisodes similaires durant leur enfance.
Donc il y a quand même quelque chose autour du trauma aussi à prendre en compte.
Donc, vous disiez le trauma. D'autres...
Alors, il y a d'autres éléments. Oui, il y a ce qu'on appelle tout ce qui peut être neuropsychologique et la,
la capacité, par exemple, de mémoire, d'organisation, de planification de certains de nos patients, puisque pour certains, c'est un trouble, on a pu montrer qu'elle était défaillante.
Donc c'est comme s'il y avait un rapport au monde qui est un petit peu défaillant et qui pourrait peut-être les pousser vers un certain nombre d'actes qui leur est plus accessible.
Assez prosaïquement, il est plus facile de séduire une petite fille qu'une femme adulte. Et donc, dans ce cadre-là...
Ça a été démontré, ça ? Ça me paraît très étrange comme conclusion.
Effectivement, ça peut être tout à fait discuté, mais c'est ce qui ressort des discussions qu'on a avec eux. C'est que...
Les séduire vraiment en termes d'obtenir un sourire, obtenir un développement d'une relation, quelque chose comme ça.
Oui ok, peut-être qu'elles mettent moins leur garde.
Oui, c'est... Il y a cette naïveté enfantine qui pour le coup est,
peut pas avoir des conséquences difficiles. Alors, on a pu aussi mettre en évidence que certaines personnes qui présentent un trouble paraphilique ont vraiment un rapport au monde qui est compliqué, une difficulté à aller vers les autres,
une tendance à l'isolement.
Et donc là aussi, le passage à l'acte pédophilique est un moyen totalement évidemment inacceptable de régler certains de leurs problèmes.
Donc, par exemple, d'aller vers les autres. Et ils vont vers les autres en ayant dans la tête
le fait, entre autres, d'avoir une excitation sexuelle pour des enfants, mais aussi de pouvoir créer des liens sociaux, des liens amicaux avec ces enfants.
Donc ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est le caractère un petit peu monstrueux qu'on prête donc aux personnes, dans ce cas-ci, on parle en particulier des personnes qui ont des traits pédophiles.
On va s'intéresser aussi à la question du fétichisme que je souhaitais explorer aussi. Moi, j'ai en tête en particulier...
C'était quoi ? C'était il y a une dizaine d'années, madame Michel ?
Michelle Martin.
Michelle Martin. Oui, c'est ça, oui. C'était Michelle Martin qui devait aller vivre, je crois, dans un couvent, sortir de prison temporairement pour s'installer dans un couvent.
Et on voyait une espèce de tribunal populaire s'installer, en particulier dans les médias, de personnes qui voulaient la brûler vive, disaient : Faut qu'elle crève, faut qu'elle crève.
Et on la diabolisait complètement. Ce qui m'apparaît comme étant une incompréhension totale, très loin de ce que vous décrivez maintenant comme étant une sexualité
qui s'est développée de façon standard, qui n'est pas un choix actif, qui n'est pas une nature qu'ils ont recherchée spontanément.
Là où je veux aller, c'est qu'il y a une incompréhension très importante de la société vis-à-vis des personnes concernées.
Sans parler en particulier de Michelle Martin. Est-ce qu'il y a des choses à faire d'après vous, en termes d'éducation, en termes de compréhension de la population vis-à-vis de ces personnes ?
C'est un sujet vaste. Et effectivement, des situations comme celles que vous évoquez démontrent bien l'incompréhension. Travailler en psychiatrie médico-légale ou en psychologie légale, c'est être constamment contre-intuitif.
Parce que tout ce qu'on pense de manière un petit peu simpliste comme étant une solution, ben finalement, on se rend compte que ce ne sont jamais les bonnes solutions.
Par exemple, on pense qu'en laissant en prison très longtemps, une fois qu'ils seront sortis, ils auront compris, ils ne recommenceront pas.
Alors que même si le taux de récidive est en général assez faible chez les délinquants sexuels, on sait très très bien que le temps en prison ne fait que renforcer la tendance à la récidive.
Donc il faut trouver un juste équilibre.
Donc la tendance à la récidive augmente, mais la récidive elle-même est assez faible.
Oui. Alors si vous voulez des chiffres, je sais que vous voulez des chiffres. Alors, les chiffres sont un peu difficiles, évidemment, de manière simpliste, à donner, mais je vais quand même essayer de le faire.
Si on prend l'ensemble des délinquants sexuels, on peut considérer qu'à peu près trente pour cent d'entre eux vont récidiver, mais de manière générale, pas uniquement en commettant un délit à caractère sexuel.
À peu près quinze à vingt pour cent d'entre eux vont commettre un délit à caractère sexuel. Par contre, si on les aide et si on met en place des programmes de soins qui leur permettent de mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
On va en parler, ouais.
On diminue clairement la récidive. Donc, il y a-
Mais comme vous disiez, la tendance à la récidive augmente-
Oui, effectivement.
Lors de la détention. C'est ça qui est très frappant en fait.
Mais oui, parce que je vais prendre un exemple. Là aussi, c'est simpliste, mais parlons d'un pédophile qui a des gros problèmes de socialisation.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour essayer de l'aider à ne pas recommencer ? Eh bien, c'est de travailler avec lui le développement de relations que nous, on appelle les relations prosociales.
C'est-à-dire développer des connaissances avec des gens qui vont plutôt être positives, avec des gens positifs, avec des gens qui sont constructifs, avec des gens qui peuvent les amener à s'intéresser à certains sujets, etc.
Il faut reconnaître que c'est pas en prison qu'on les trouve.
Mh. C'est sûr.
Et que si on veut vraiment travailler de manière active à la prévention de la récidive, eh bien, le psy que je suis va dire : « Il faut pas les mettre en prison ».
Mais je suis aussi citoyen et le citoyen dit : « Il y a quand même un aspect rétributif ». Le droit pénal insiste beaucoup sur le fait qu'une peine a un sens, une peine veut dire quelque chose.
Et donc c'est cette tension constante entre la peine nécessaire, que peut-être le citoyen appelle de ses vœux.
Voilà, pas moi spécialement, mais enfin, voilà, le citoyen lambda appelle de ses vœux. Et d'un autre côté, la nécessité de travailler sur le risque de récidive.
Et je le répète, c'est pas en prison qu'on travaille le mieux. Toutes les études montrent que c'est le soin communautaire qui marche le mieux.
Le soin communautaire, c'est quand la personne retourne dans la communauté et est aidée, pas uniquement par un psy qu'on va rencontrer toutes les semaines, par toute une série d'acteurs qui vont travailler avec lui pendant la journée
pour justement développer toute une série de compétences.
Et c'est pas du tout en prison que ça se travaille. Ça se démarre en prison parce qu'il faut bien qu'on démarre quelque part, mais le gros du travail se fait à l'extérieur de la prison.
Donc ça, c'est pour ce qui est de, du, entre guillemets, de l'accompagnement, entre gros guillemets, du traitement. Mais pour retourner à ma question qui était sur le,
l'incompréhension, la difficulté à établir un dialogue, à comprendre les personnes et à vraiment surtout les diaboliser, ce qui est le réflexe numéro un vis-à-vis des personnes concernées par la pédophilie.
Je peux comprendre ce sentiment. On touche à un tabou quand il s'agit d'enfants. On touche un tabou quand il s'agit de, effectivement, de faits qui créent des traumatismes parfois terribles.
Et il est difficile de ne pas mettre des émotions dans des situations pareilles.
Bien sûr. C'est très compréhensible.
C'est loin d'être idéal. Et moi, j'ai beaucoup de chance d'avoir travaillé avec des gens comme ça parce que j'avais appris, avant, pendant et même après, certaines choses qui m'ont permis de prendre de la distance avec ça.
Et donc toutes les convictions que j'ai, qui sont des relatives certitudes scientifiques, avec tout ce que ça vaut, viennent de lectures, de formations, de rencontres avec eux qui me permettent d'attester que,
par exemple, les peines de prison n'ont pas d'effet positif sur ces personnes.
Mais voilà, c'est aussi parce que le regard scientifique s'est posé là-dessus. Mais en tant que citoyen, effectivement, j'ai pas spécialement d'attirance pour ce genre de personnage.
Oui, oui. Donc, pour revenir à ma question, est-ce qu'il y a des efforts à faire à ce niveau-là ou est-ce que vous pensez que c'est mal barré ?
Non, je pense que y a-- Évitons évidemment toute forme de populisme à ce sujet. Ça, c'est un élément important.
Il y en a encore parfois qui se lâchent avec des convictions que plus on enferme, plus on contrôle, plus on contraint, mieux ça ira.
Sincèrement, dans notre domaine, c'est pas vrai, c'est le contraire qui fonctionne. Donc, voilà, nous,
ce qu'on a à faire, c'est peut-être des podcasts comme on le fait aujourd'hui, c'est informer les gens de bonne volonté, mais surtout, surtout, surtout, continuer à faire notre métier de manière la plus
scientifique qui soit.
Ça, c'est vraiment important de ne pas se laisser entraîner par un camp comme par l'autre et d'essayer d'être le plus distant, le plus froid, le plus carré sur la manière dont on aborde ce type de problématique.
Mh. Mh. J'aimerais revenir sur votre réponse. Il y a un instant, vous disiez que certaines rencontres, certaines expériences vous avaient amené à, si tu veux, changer votre perspective sur toutes ces questions ?
Oui, parce que, voilà, comme médecin-
Concrètement, est-ce que vous avez des exemples ?
Comme médecin, comme psychiatre, j'ai été formé à soigner des maladies.
Mh.
Et
mes premières rencontres avec des agresseurs sexuels m'ont
confirmé qu'en fait, ils n'avaient pas de maladie et que derrière, parfois, cette carapace assez monstrueuse, vous utilisez le mot de monstre, se trouvent parfois des gens éminemment bien plus complexes que ce que j'imaginais.
Et ça me fait penser qu'à l'époque, quand j'ai démarré mon activité avec eux, j'avais écrit un article sur ce sujet et un des, je pense, un des paragraphes s'appelait : « Zut, j'ai ri avec un pédophile ».
Parce que je me souviens qu'à l'époque, j'avais passé un bon moment avec un de ces personnages,
qui était patient dans l'unité dans laquelle je travaillais et que évidemment, une fois passé le moment de la connaissance des faits qui avaient été faits, 'fin, des faits de ces personnes,
eh bien, je me retrouve avec des gens qui, par ailleurs, ont la capacité de s'amuser, qui, par ailleurs, avec qui on peut passer des très bons moments,
tout comme il y en a d'autres avec qui je passerais pas mes vacances, mais d'autres avec qui je peux vraiment passer des très bons moments.
Et donc, ce que j'ai vraiment appris, c'est que les monstres, ça n'existe pas, que les actes peuvent être monstrueux, mais que le monstre n'existe pas.
Peut-être un ou deux. Évidemment, il y a toujours une extrémité, mais en général, ce sont des personnes qui ont vécu des grosses difficultés dans leur vie, qui ont commis des choses qu'elles ne pouvaient pas commettre.
Et donc, comme toute personne sur cette terre, on est tous un petit peu de chair, d'esprit, de sentiments et que y a finalement pas énormément de différences entre eux et nous.
Oui, oui. Alors, on va explorer les questions d'accompagnement, les questions aussi légales, puisque vous avez été vous-même un expert qui a travaillé, qui avait travaillé dans ce contexte-là.
Mais avant de passer sur ces aspects-là, juste revenir donc sur la question du fétichisme, puisqu'on n'a pas encore exploré ça-
Ah, c'est vrai, ouais.
En profondeur. J'ai quelques exemples qui me viennent à l'esprit, mais le plus simple serait, je pense que, de-- Le plus simple serait, je pense, de vous demander qu'est-ce que c'est le fétichisme, concrètement ?
Est-ce que vous avez des exemples ?
Le fétichisme, c'est une, donc une paraphilie qui est centrée sur l'utilisation préférentielle d'objets inanimés.
J'ai en tête aussi une personne que j'ai rencontrée qui avait développé un fétichisme sur, c'est pas très original, mais sur des petites culottes et qui en avait mis partout chez lui.
Et donc l'excitation sexuelle venait de cette collection de petites culottes. Et là où
on voit la différence entre paraphilie et trouble paraphilique, c'est qu'à la limite, le fait d'aller dans un grand magasin d'acheter des petites culottes, c'est évidemment moralement un petit peu bizarre, c'est un peu rébarbatif,
mais est-ce que ça cause des victimes ?
Est-ce que c'est une première étape vers un trouble ?
Est-ce que ça cause une souffrance chez la personne ?
Alors exactement, c'est à ça que je voulais venir, c'est que cette personne, à certains moments, en souffrait énormément.
Ah d'accord, ok.
Grosse culpabilité,
anxiété, grosse difficulté à pouvoir imaginer par ailleurs se retrouver dans un environnement où il y aurait des petites filles, puisqu'il y avait chez lui quand même aussi, au-delà de ce fétichisme, des petits traits pédophiliques.
Et donc c'est une personne qui vient en disant : Je peux plus vivre avec ça, c'est trop compliqué, j'en souffre trop. Mais ça, c'est une forme de fétichisme.
Alors, les fétichismes les plus souvent rencontrés, c'est quand il s'agit d'une orientation vers les femmes.
Ce sont par exemple les robes en soie. Il y a la fourrure.
Les chaussures.
Ça peut être les chaussures, les hauts talons. Il y a toute une fantasmatique autour de ça. Et j'ai en tête un patient assez impressionnant, terriblement fétichiste, qui était, lui, très orienté vers les baskets
et les chaussures de sport.
Et lorsqu'il venait me rencontrer, il prenait le train et se mettait sous les sièges de train pour pouvoir contempler les chaussures des gens dans le train.
Et donc, quand il venait me voir en consultation, on commençait toujours par discuter de ce qu'il avait vu dans le train et comment il avait géré.
Ça peut être drôle, parfois, la psychiatrie. Et donc oui, ce sont des situations parfois assez étonnantes.
Et puis oui, alors il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle, nous, les psychiatres, le partialisme. Le partialisme, c'est un intérêt pour des parties a priori non sexualisées du corps.
Et là aussi, c'est une construction qu'on peut-
Les pieds, ouais.
Les pieds, ça, c'est effectivement un partialisme très fréquemment rencontré. Et puis ça pose aussi la question de parties qui seraient sexualisées ou de parties qui ne seraient pas sexualisées dans le corps humain.
Et donc là aussi, c'est une vaste question.
Il y a aussi une question de construction sociale là-dedans.
Ah totalement, totalement.
Culturelle.
Et qui peut aussi être déconstruite. Et donc là aussi, ça démontre bien que la psychiatrie tente à certains égards de capter un peu l'air du temps.
Mais au travers encore de notions comme le fétichisme, le partialisme, on est un petit peu perdu face à l'évolution de la société.
Mmm-hmm.
Et si vous vouliez parler de fétichisme, je voulais dire un petit mot du transvestisme, peut-être.
Oui, pourquoi pas ?
Parce que ça, c'est un bon exemple. Donc le transvestisme, c'est cette tendance qu'ont, à la base, de manière théorique, certains hommes de s'habiller en femme et d'en éprouver un plaisir sexuel.
C'est un des huit troubles paraphiliques qu'on retrouve dans les classifications psychiatriques. Mais il y a un gros problème, si tant est que c'est un problème, c'est qu'on a très rarement vu
des hommes qui sont porteurs d'un transvestisme en souffrir réellement.
Oui, donc c'est pas un trouble.
Pourtant, les classifications nous disent que ça peut être un trouble, mais les études ne le montrent pas.
Oui, mais ce qui reviendrait peut-être à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, l'aspect peut-être un peu normatif, l'aspect très-
Exactement.
On reste dans des cases très standards. Il faut surtout pas dépasser quand on dessine.
Et ouais, ouais.
Dans ce cadre-là, les normes ont beaucoup évolué ces dernières années. Le fait comme ça qu'il y ait même des émissions de télé avec des drag queens qui même valorisaient cette image du transvestisme
a beaucoup fait pour vraiment complètement ringardiser le transvestisme comme étant un trouble.
Et là, on se rend compte qu'en fait, la souffrance vient peut-être du regard social.
Moi, j'ai en tête une personne qui s'habille en femme, qui ne-- qui pouvait sortir que le soir très très tard pour être sûr de rencontrer personne dans la rue pour éviter d'être rejeté.
Alors peut-être que les-- dans dix, quinze, vingt ans, on admettra ce type de comportement sans le moindre problème et ça partira lors de nos classifications sans faire de bruit.
Mmm-hmm. Oui, c'est un exemple intéressant puisqu'effectivement, enfin, comme je le disais il y a un instant, on,
on sent que la psychiatrie peut être très violente avec les personnes qui dépassent, qui sortent des normes.
Et voilà, donc on parlait de personnes qui font du transvestisme, mais donc ça touche aussi donc indirectement les personnes, les drag queens, comme vous disiez.
Et puis peut-être que la personne dont vous venez de parler, qui n'osait sortir que tard le soir, aurait pu entamer une question de transition de genre quoi.
Mais effectivement, la psychiatrie a pu l'être et est encore en partie aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez normatif.
Ah oui, c'est clairement quelque chose de normatif et-
De violente, du coup.
Et à nous chaque fois de ramener les choses à la question de la détresse, qu'on a évoquée au début, la question de dysfonctionnement, la question de victimisation ou de victime tout court.
Ce sont des éléments dont on-- sur lesquels on va chaque fois s'arrêter.
Mmm-hmm. Donc, les notions de fétichisme et de, vous disiez partialisme.
Ah, de partialisme, oui. Bien, bien retenu, oui.
Donc là, l'exemple le plus frappant qu'on m'avait donné à moi, c'était
le cas d'une personne qui, quand il était petit, avait perdu sa mère dans un accident et donc il l'avait vue pour la dernière fois avec des plâtres, vraiment blessée, vraiment les os cassés dans tout son corps.
Et apparemment, ce qui se-- concrètement, ce qui se passait, c'est qu'à l'âge adulte, il exigeait, lors des relations sexuelles avec son épouse, qu'elle mette des faux plâtres.
Donc ça, c'est l'exemple, bon, je sais pas si ça se voit vraiment dans le-
Ah comme ça, j'ai jamais rencontré, non. Effectivement.
C'est ce qu'on m'a raconté. C'est une sexologue qui m'a raconté ça.
Ah ben, c'est tout à fait envisageable, mais c'est vrai que j'ai jamais rencontré. Et gardons-nous bien toujours de faire des liens de cause à effet aussi là-dedans.
Ah ok.
Parce que le, voilà, le
Dans notre domaine, psy, psychiatrique ou psychologique, il faut reconnaître qu'on n'a jamais pu définir de manière sûre et certaine et objective qu'un événement, un comportement était dû à une cause unique.
On n'est pas comme dans certaines disciplines médicales où on sait d'où vient le diabète, on a un problème d'insuline, etc.
J'ai-- dans notre domaine-
On sait d'ailleurs pas d'où vient le diabète, mais .
Bien vu. Bien vu. Je suis pas diabétologue, mais voilà, je-
Mais on sait qu'il y a des facteurs génétiques et qu'il y a-
C'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est vrai. Mais on connaît plus ou moins le processus et on sait sur quoi travailler pour éviter qu'il se développe-
Oui, pour le soigner, oui, oui
...pour s'aggraver. Dans notre domaine, on va être très très profil bas, très modeste et utiliser ces hypothèses de cause à effet comme étant plutôt des hypothèses de travail.
On va se dire : « C'est peut-être ça, mais on va travailler là-dessus ». Mais ne jamais trop insister sur une cause unique qui finalement n'a d'intérêt que si elle est travaillée, donc par exemple en psychothérapie.
Donc, mais donc c'est intéressant cette question de partialisme et de fétichisme.
Oui, je vois que ça vous intéresse, effectivement.
On a-- Ben, ou c'est un petit segment sur notre interview, mais j'allais, je-- Ce qui est intéressant, c'est particulièrement le fait que
on a du mal à imaginer quelqu'un en souffrance, quelqu'un qui-- Ben, vous avez donné l'exemple de la personne qui vivait très mal le fait d'avoir ce fétichisme sur les petites culottes.
Là, on voit que la souffrance vient dans ce, en tout cas dans le cas que vous avez donné, surtout, encore une fois, de la norme sociale et de ce qui est considéré comme étant normal ou anormal,
là où dans les exemples de paraphilie comme la pédophilie, par exemple, y a évidemment aussi la question de la norme sociale, mais il y a surtout la question du consentement,
là où elle se pose beaucoup moins sur la question de fétichisme et de partialisme.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est ce que les classifications, là aussi, le fameux DSM, parce que je parle des classifications, mais le DSM, qui est notre boussole un peu, nous, les psychiatres,
insistent beaucoup sur cette notion de consentement.
Et quand le consentement n'est pas présent, on est vraiment plus, je dirais, dans cette approche de trouble.
Quand je parlais du passage de la paraphilie au trouble paraphilique, ce qui fait le passage de l'un à l'autre, c'est la notion de détresse, c'est la notion aussi de victime.
Et donc, pour qu'il y ait une victime, il faut qu'il n'y ait pas eu de consentement. En tout cas, dans un certain nombre de cas.
Mais clairement, l'absence de consentement définit pour la médecine le passage d'une paraphilie au trouble paraphilique.
Et c'est aussi ça qui définit le délit, le crime. Le code pénal, qui a été revu d'ailleurs par rapport aux délits sexuels récemment,
insiste énormément sur la notion de consentement, au point même que parfois, c'est très compliqué de définir si une personne est consentante ou pas.
Mais néanmoins, le droit dans le code pénal et la médecine dans notre classification, entre le DSM, définissent le consentement comme étant le pivot entre le normal et le pathologique, entre ce qui est légal et ce qui est illégal.
Et donc, revenons alors à la question de l'accompagnement pour les personnes qui viennent chercher de l'aide ou qui sont contraintes parce qu'elles ont été jugées...
Finalement, concrètement, les personnes avec lesquelles vous avez travaillé, est-ce qu'il y a une proportion entre les personnes qui, spontanément, sont venues chercher de l'aide, par exemple en faisant le constat
d'une paraphilie ou d'une déviance sexuelle
avec laquelle ils auraient du mal à vivre, par rapport aux personnes qui sont contraintes à travailler avec vous pour soigner un trouble ?
Je crois que je suis un peu biaisé par ça, parce que j'ai commencé mon activité directement dans une population médico-légale qui était déjà sous contrainte et à qui on imposait un suivi chez moi ou une hospitalisation dans mon service.
Donc j'ai vu une immense majorité de personnes sous contrainte. J'ai vu quelques personnes qui venaient me voir vraiment pour des plaintes spontanément.
Ça, j'en ai déjà vu. Je pense que si on interroge des sexologues, on verra peut-être plus des plaintes spontanées.
Donc je pense que tout est un petit peu possible. Moi, j'ai vraiment plus cette vision quand même de la paraphilie comme étant, et du trouble paraphilie, comme étant une obligation de soins.
C'est plutôt ce type de clientèle et de patientèle que j'ai.
Mh, mh, mh. Donc oui, donc un biais de sélection parmi les personnes que vous avez eu l'occasion de rencontrer. Mais est-ce que vous pouvez parler de travaux que vous menez donc avec ces personnes pour, 'fin, on l'a déjà un petit peu évoqué,
avant, pour essayer de
les aider, donc, à déjà ne plus passer à l'acte, les aider à peut-être travailler sur leur mal-être.
Sur quoi est-ce que vous travaillez avec ces personnes ?
On peut faire évidemment plein de choses. Je vais essayer d'être bon et d'en dire quatre.
Allez-y.
La première chose, c'est ce que vous venez de dire, c'est de travailler sur tout ce qu'il y a autour. Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on passe de fantasmes à l'acte ?
Ça peut être de l'anxiété, ça peut être de la consommation de substances. Donc ça veut dire que là, on va avoir une approche, je dirais, plus classique d'un point de vue psychiatrique.
On traite quelqu'un qui est anxieux, on traite quelqu'un qui a une dépendance alcoolique, on traite quelqu'un qui a une dépression.
Donc ce genre de choses, on peut le faire. La deuxième méthode, c'est ce qu'on appelle le cycle de l'addiction. C'est qu'on va un petit peu greffer sur ce type de situation ce qui se passe un peu dans les addictions.
C'est-à-dire qu'on va considérer que des passages à l'acte sexuel sont un peu comme une personne qui consomme de l'héroïne, qui consomme de l'alcool, qui consomme du cannabis
et qu'il passe par ce que nous, psy, on appelle le cycle d'addiction, c'est-à-dire une période
où on n'est pas bien, où on se dit que le produit va nous aider à aller mieux.
On passe par une période de recherche du produit, on consomme, ça va un petit peu mieux, puis le cycle se réamorce. Et donc il y a quand même tout un pan du traitement des délinquants sexuels qui utilise ce cycle de l'addiction.
Mais qui est pas super efficace.
Mmh.
En tout cas, seule. C'est pas super efficace. J'en ai déjà dit deux. Le troisième, c'est la notion d'hypersexualité. On peut aussi aborder
la sexualité déviante, les paraphilies, le passage à l'acte, en considérant qu'il s'agit d'une mauvaise gestion, d'une difficulté à gérer une sexualité débordante.
Et donc, on se retrouve face à des patients qui nous disent : « Je pense à ça toute la journée. J'ai une libido débordante, je dois avoir plusieurs relations sexuelles par jour ou bien je passe
des heures à me masturber en ayant des pensées impures, que sais-je.
» Et donc, là, il y a aussi une approche qui est, pour schématiser, peut-être plutôt médicamenteuse et qui permet globalement d'améliorer les choses.
Ça, c'est la troisième. Et puis la quatrième, qui est loin d'être exclusive des autres, parce que j'aborde les choses schématiquement, tout ça peut se cumuler, c'est ce qu'on appelle les programmes de soins.
Et ça, c'est vraiment les choses qui ont le plus d'efficacité. Les programmes de soins, ce sont très simplement des
groupes thérapeutiques auxquels participent les agresseurs sexuels et qui vont aborder toute une série de facteurs de risque qui, une fois pris en charge, leur permettent de diminuer la récidive.
Par exemple, j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure, on peut tout à fait travailler avec eux le fait de développer des compétences sociales, donc des compétences prosociales, pour développer des relations correctes avec les gens.
On peut les aider à trouver une certaine satisfaction, à exercer une activité professionnelle, à avoir des activités de loisirs, à avoir une vie familiale.
Le fait parfois d'isoler les personnes qui ont des paraphilies ou des troubles paraphiliques, ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens.
Le plus possible, il faut créer du lien social. Mais il y a aussi une notion de risque à prendre en compte, donc c'est plus compliqué.
Ces programmes de soins ont montré que si la personne s'engageait, eh bien, ça pouvait réduire de moitié le risque de récidive.
Je parlais tout à l'heure de 15, 20 %. On est à un peu plus de 5 %, dans certains cas, un peu moins de 10 % de récidive lorsque les personnes suivent correctement ces programmes de soins.
Et quand j'évoquais les relations prosociales, il s'agit aussi, on pourrait en parler des heures, mais de gestion des émotions, de compréhension de ce qu'est la loi, de pouvoir mieux gérer certaines interactions.
Quand, par exemple, c'est des choses très prosaïques, mais quand vous draguez une fille en boîte de nuit et qu'elle dit non, comment est-ce que vous gérez votre colère ?
Mmh.
S'il y en a une.
Je peux vous assurer que c'est des choses qu'on travaille avec eux et que lorsqu'ils arrivent à développer des stratégies pour être moins en colère, eh bien, c'est des choses qu'ils peuvent utiliser lorsqu'ils vivent certaines frustrations.
Et donc, j'ai cité quatre champs de traitements qui, comme je le disais, peuvent se cumuler.
Mmh.
On peut tout à fait imaginer, par exemple, qu'une personne, dans le cadre d'un programme de soins, puisse être sous traitement comme ce qu'on appelle un traitement de castration chimique.
Les quatre grands champs qui peuvent se combiner. Voilà, on peut voir ces questions-là à travers le prisme de l'addiction.
Ce que disent les addicts, par exemple, qui consomment ou qui ont consommé des drogues dures, c'est que c'est : « It's a lifelong thing. »
Ouais.
C'est un truc qui dure toute une vie, contre lequel ils doivent lutter toute la vie. Alors, pour reprendre le cas, voilà, des personnes qui ont été aidées, qui ont eu accès à ces soins,
vous disiez, voilà, 90, 95 % des personnes concernées
ne récidivent plus à ce moment-là.
Est-ce qu'elles restent malgré tout dans une situation de tentation éternelle, de résistance à des idées, à des besoins qui leur viendraient ?
Oui, oui.
À quoi est-ce qu'on fait face ?
Oui, oui, effectivement, c'est-- on ne change pas d'orientation sexuelle comme ça. D'ailleurs-
Ah, vous appelez ça une orientation sexuelle ?
Ah oui, tout à fait. Oui, c'est-
OK.
Il y a des personnes hétérosexuelles, il y a des personnes homosexuelles, il y a des personnes, évidemment, qui sont pansexuelles, il y a des personnes qui sont attirées par des enfants, par des plus jeunes, par des plus vieux.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que dans tout ce que je viens de dire, il y a des choses qu'on ne peut pas faire, il y a des choses illégales.
Ah, bien sûr.
Et la seule différence, elle est là. Quand je dis ça, c'est parfois très compliqué d'entendre ça. Parce que moralement-
Effectivement, il y a des gens qui sont en train de bugger en nous écoutant là.
Alors, je vais les rassurer tout de suite pour dire que je me mets pas du tout dans le champ de la loi, enfin, dans le champ de la loi, certes, mais pas dans le champ de la morale.
Je veux dire que dans leur tête, c'est quelque chose qui est plus ou moins du même ordre. Et ce que je veux toujours être, c'est stratégique.
C'est-à-dire que quand on lance une option thérapeutique, parmi toutes celles que j'ai citées, là tout de suite, il s'agit pas de diaboliser leur orientation sexuelle parce qu'ils vont devoir vivre avec toute leur vie.
Une personne qui est pédophile, le but, c'est qu'elle reste pédophile dans sa tête, mais qu'elle ne passe pas à l'acte. Donc le but n'est pas qu'elle reste pédophile, c'est qu'elle ne passe pas à l'acte.
Et donc on doit pouvoir parler de ça. On doit pouvoir s'entendre sur le fait que le traitement ne va pas les réorienter ou les orienter, comme certains zozos pensent qu'on peut soigner l'homosexualité.
Oui, thérapie de conversion, ça n'existe pas.
Exactement. Il n'y a pas de thérapie de conversion des pédophiles vers une sexualité adulte. C'est la même chose.
Donc cette situation sera dans leur tête toute leur vie. Je l'ai dit tout à l'heure, la grande majorité des gens qui ont ça dans leur tête ne passent pas à l'acte.
Le but, c'est que ceux qui sont passés à l'acte rejoignent la cohorte des personnes qui n'ont jamais passé à l'acte.
Mmh.
Et donc, effectivement, c'est plus de tentations, c'est plus de pensées qui sont parfois douloureuses parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas être assouvies,
mais c'est normal parce qu'on ne peut pas faire ça, parce que ça crée des victimes, ça crée des traumatismes et donc on ne le fait pas.
Mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut parfois les accompagner longtemps. Ou bien il y en a certains qui, assez,
relativement rapidement, c'est-- on parle quand même en mois ou en petites années, développent suffisamment de compétences, de stratégies pour être suffisamment solides.
Et là, le suivi peut s'arrêter.
Stratégies comme ? Quand elles font face, par exemple, à une image ou une rencontre qui déclenche quelque chose chez elle, qu'est-ce que-- quelle est la stratégie ?
Quel est le réflexe à avoir dans ce cas-là ?
Alors là, on revient vraiment dans les modèles de thérapie cognitivo-comportementale où les personnes font l'apprentissage de comportements qui leur permettent de juguler leur...
Y a un mot, tiens, qu'on n'a pas dit depuis le début, le mot « pulsion ». Et c'est bien parce que je déteste ce mot « pulsion ».
C'est moi qui le prononçais ?
Oui oui, c'est chouette que vous l'ayez pas prononcé. Donc « pulsion », ça veut pas dire grand-chose, sauf en psychanalyse.
Mais la pulsion, je dis ça un peu en souriant, parce que la pulsion, c'est ce que nous disent à peu près tous les auteurs quand on les rencontre la première fois.
On leur demande : « Pourquoi vous avez fait ça ? » Il dit : « C'est une pulsion. » Comme si c'était quelque chose qu'on ne pouvait pas contrôler ou expliquer.
Non, y a pas de zone pulsionnelle dans le cerveau qui fait qu'il y a des choses qu'on peut pas contrôler. Moi, je parle plutôt d'attirance et donc les gens peuvent apprendre à contrôler leur attirance.
Et ça, s'ils le font correctement, ce qu'eux ils appellent une pulsion, ça devient une attirance et cette attirance, il faut apprendre à la contrôler.
Apprendre à contrôler, oui. C'est donc pas très concret en fait, comme stratégie...
Ah alors, moi, je peux être très concret.
Oui, allez-y.
Alors, une chose qu'on fait par exemple avec certaines personnes, c'est leur demander des devoirs. Donc, ils viennent nous voir lors d'une première séance.
Donc imaginons un programme de soins où entre deux séances, donc le groupe se réunit, on identifie les moments où c'est compliqué.
Eh bien, lors d'une séance, on leur dira : « Pour la semaine prochaine, vous identifiez les étapes qui ont mené au passage à l'acte.
» Et donc ils prennent leur petit cahier, ils notent tout ça pendant la semaine. Ils notent aussi les moments où ça a été plus compliqué.
Et avec eux, on retravaille chacune de ces étapes et on définit chaque fois des échappatoires.
C'est très TCC là pour le coup.
Ah, ça, c'est hyper TCC à l'ancienne, vraiment, c'est vintage, XXe siècle.
Donc TCC, thérapie cognitive-
Cognitivo-comportementale. Mais ça marche plutôt bien. Et là évidemment, je prends un exemple un petit peu, là aussi, un peu schématique, mais chacune de ces étapes va être l'occasion, par exemple via des jeux de rôle,
de pouvoir créer chez eux un nouvel apprentissage.
Mmm-hmm.
Dans nos modèles thérapeutiques, on dit toujours une chose que là aussi, certains pourraient considérer comme étant un peu incompréhensible, mais je vais essayer d'expliquer, c'est que le passage à l'acte criminel, c'est un apprentissage.
On apprend à devenir criminel. On apprend parce qu'on a des relations pro-criminelles, parce que certains nous disent qu'on peut le faire, parce qu'on pense qu'on peut le faire.
Moi, je pense vraiment, un peu de manière rousseauiste, que finalement, on n'est plutôt pas des méchantes personnes quand on naît,
mais que petit à petit, certains s'orientent vers la voie criminelle parce que c'est à certains moments plus simple, plus facile, ça leur apporte plus de bénéfices, etc., etc.
Y compris dans la délinquance sexuelle.
Donc le délit sexuel est en soi une certaine forme d'apprentissage. Donc ils apprennent à agresser sexuellement pour pouvoir atteindre certains objectifs, et ce, de manière plus simple que s'ils utilisaient d'autres moyens.
Notre idée, c'est que le fait de sortir de ce comportement-là, c'est aussi un apprentissage. Donc, on va désapprendre certaines choses.
Et donc l'exemple du cahier, des petites notes de manière très thérapie cognitivo-comportementale, en effet un peu classique, c'est un moyen parmi d'autres pour leur inculquer de nouveaux schémas de pensée.
Il y a un truc qui marche aussi pas mal, c'est la psychoéducation. Et ça peut paraître là aussi un peu étonnant, mais,
l'éducation sexuelle comme celle qu'on a eue ou qu'on devrait avoir à l'école, c'est des choses que pour eux, la plupart du temps, ils n'ont pas eues.
Donc il faut leur expliquer-
Mmm-hmm.
Comment fonctionne le système reproducteur chez l'homme, chez la femme, sont des choses-- j'ai entendu des choses étonnantes.
Des personnes qui ne savaient pas ce qu'était un vagin, parce qu'ils ne savaient pas que le vagin était séparé du système urinaire, par exemple.
C'est des choses que j'ai-
C'est pas si rare que ça.
Hein ?
Les hommes, les hommes qui sont persuadés que ça, ça a les mêmes trous, c'est...
Bah voilà.
Y a des lacunes dans notre système d'éducation. C'est vraiment...
Une information
de ce type-là permet vraiment aux personnes aussi de constituer finalement encore plus de connaissances qui participent évidemment, pas de manière définitive bien sûr, mais qui participent à une meilleure connaissance de soi, des autres
et donc à la prévention de la récidive.
Ça, c'est pour ce qui est la question de l'accompagnement, la question des personnes, donc, qui doivent, entre guillemets,
contrôler une addiction au cours de leur vie, pour appeler ça comme ça, pour voir ça sous le prisme de l'addiction ou en tout cas, voilà, réprimer une--
finalement, c'est réprimer une orientation sexuelle, pour reprendre votre terme.
Oui, on peut dire ça, réprimer dans le sens de pouvoir en canaliser les éventuelles conséquences comportementales, en tout cas.
Mmm-hmm. C'est ça. Et donc on n'a pas encore parlé finalement de la question judiciaire, la question pénale. Donc, vous disiez que vous étiez appelé comme expert au sein du tribunal.
Donc c'était quoi ? C'était au pénal ? C'était...
Oui, c'est au pénal. Il y a de très bons psychiatres qui travaillent au civil. Moi, je connais pas ce domaine-là, mais au pénal, on est de plus en plus souvent amené à donner un avis au moment du travail.
Par exemple, pendant l'enquête, le juge d'instruction demande un avis d'un psychiatre. Ça peut se faire parfois de manière aiguë ou bien pendant le temps de la détention préventive.
Un juge d'instruction ou même un juge peut demander un avis d'un psychiatre quant au trouble psychiatrique que présenterait la personne qui a commis certains actes à caractère sexuel ou pas d'ailleurs.
Et donc notre mission dans ces moments-là, c'est d'évaluer la responsabilité en fait de la personne. Est-ce que c'était une personne qui était pleinement en mesure de décider ce qu'elle a fait ou ce qu'elle n'a pas fait ?
Est-ce qu'au moment des faits, elle était en capacité ? Est-ce qu'elle présentait un trouble mental ? Est-ce qu'elle était responsable en fait de ses actes ?
Et donc ça, c'est une mission importante qui peut être interrogée dans le cadre évidemment des troubles paraphiliques, parce qu'on a beaucoup de questionnements sur le fait que est-ce que le fait de présenter un trouble paraphilique
peut permettre d'abolir la responsabilité ?
Donc là, c'est vraiment du cas par cas, c'est assez compliqué. C'est un petit peu
difficile d'expliquer ça en quelques minutes, mais il faut là aussi être très très prudent parce que si on met en fin d'expertise cette personne présentant un trouble pédophilique,
ce qui est parfois le cas, il faut quand même se rendre compte de toutes les conséquences que ça peut avoir pour cette personne.
Puisque si elle n'est pas condamnée, mais plutôt internée, c'est-à-dire considérée comme irresponsable de ses actes-
Ça peut arriver ? Ça-
C'est arrivé, oui. Un petit peu moins maintenant, mais dans le décours de l'affaire Dutroux, beaucoup de personnes qui présentaient un trouble paraphilique ont été internées.
Eh bien, on se retrouve devant une situation qui est éminemment difficile puisqu'on ne peut a priori les libérer que quand on a traité le problème.
Mais traiter le problème, comme on l'a dit ici tout au long de l'émission, on ne peut pas traiter le fond du problème.
On peut traiter les comportements qui sont induits par le fond du problème. Et donc c'est chaque fois de la négociation avec les tribunaux, avec la personne aussi qui doit montrer qu'elle sache et,
et pouvoir démontrer que son comportement a changé.
Donc là, on est vraiment dans des zones un petit peu complexes. Et donc tout l'enjeu de l'expertise psychiatrique au pénal est là quoi, c'est de définir si la personne est, au moment des faits, responsable ou pas de ses actes.
Donc, vous avez mentionné le fait que la prison était en rien une solution et que ça, ça faisait beaucoup de mal au développement d'un comportement sain chez ces personnes.
Concrètement, une personne donc qui serait condamnée pour une agression, sur une, sur un ou une mineure, condamnée à combien d'années en prison ?
Qu'est-ce que vous observez, en fait, en termes de développement de leur, oui, leur comportement, de contrôle vis-à-vis de, vis-à-vis de leurs pulsions ?
Non, pardon. Vis-à-vis de, vis-à-vis de leur comportement.
Ben, là, on est dans une attitude, encore un paradoxe hein, où comme je le disais, l'enfermement, la coercition est en général plutôt un facteur qui-
Aggravant.
Aggravant. J'hésitais à dire aggravant parce que je me dis que, que, que pour certains, ça n'augmente ou ça n'augmente pas, ça ne diminue pas les risques de récidive.
Mais globalement, en effet, ce n'est pas une excellente chose que de les enfermer. Je parle d'un point de vue de nouveau de risque de récidive, simplement.
Et d'un point de vue médical aussi, ouais.
D'un point de vue médical aussi. Par contre, c'est quand même une manière de pouvoir capter un certain nombre de personnes à qui on peut proposer quand même et parfois imposer-
Mh.
Je parlais de programme de soins.
Ouais.
Ils sont sur place, c'est en prison, ils peuvent être-- leur libération conditionnelle peut être liée au fait, par exemple, de suivre ces programmes de soins.
Et ça, je dirais que c'est plutôt une bonne chose parce que, si on peut capter un certain nombre de personnes avec des outils efficaces qui permettent de diminuer la récidive,
ben, c'est plutôt pas mal que de pouvoir les cibler et, et leur faire passer toutes ces, ces stratégies thérapeutiques.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà fait face à des personnes qui, donc face à une, voilà, dans une situation où ils sont contraints de suivre un programme de soins,
n'ont vraiment pas envie ou n'acceptent pas du tout le fait, la notion que c'est un comportement inacceptable ?
Oui, oui, j'en ai déjà, déjà rencontré. Alors, ça pose la question de ce que nous, on appelle les comorbidités, c'est-à-dire-
Mh.
Quels sont les troubles à côté de ça qui peuvent peut-être justifier d'une tendance au mensonge, d'une tendance à la manipulation.
Donc, je pense évidemment aux personnalités antisociales, voire psychopathiques aussi, il y en a quand même quelques-uns.
Mais j'aimerais quand même insister sur le fait qu'on a développé des stratégies et des méthodes, comme par exemple l'entretien motivationnel, pour amener une personne à s'intéresser à sa propre vie, à s'intéresser à ses déviances.
Ce n'est pas facile hein, d'aller vers quelqu'un, lui dire : « Écoutez, on pense que vous avez, vous êtes pédophile ».
J'ai rarement vu quelqu'un qui sautait de joie en disant : « Chouette, je vais faire un programme de soins pour travailler ça ».
Donc il y a très souvent une résistance, une réticence assez légitime. Ben, c'est là que
notre compétence doit pouvoir s'exprimer au travers de stratégies comme l'entretien motivationnel qui leur permet petit à petit de contempler leur situation pour petit à petit l'admettre, la digérer et la travailler.
Très bien. Et on arrive au bout des Septante Minutes Ensemble, Pierre Oswald. Est-ce qu'il y a un dernier point que vous souhaitez explorer, qu'on n'aurait pas encore abordé ensemble ?
Ben non, je pense qu'on a quand même fait un tour de la question assez large. J'espère avoir fait passer le message d'une, d'une nuance à avoir dans des cas pareils, de, de stratégies qui doivent être le plus possible
standardisées, assez concrètes et qui nous permettent non seulement d'être en général plus efficaces, mais aussi de laisser nos émotions aux vestiaires.
Et c'est vraiment ça qu'on doit essayer de faire. Et que
lorsqu'on est dans, dans des dispositions de devoir côtoyer, travailler avec eux, on doit quand même toujours se dire qu'en face de nous, c'est des êtres humains et qu'agir avec nos émotions, ce n'est pas leur rendre service.
Et donc on doit pouvoir être suffisamment compétent, oserais-je dire, mais suffisamment outillé que, que pour au moins leur devoir ça.
On leur doit de leur apporter toute une série d'outils qui pourraient leur permettre de ne pas recommencer. Il n'y a pas non plus, et là aussi, la morale n'intervient pas.
Il ne faut pas les punir. Nous, nous, nous, on est des soignants. Il y a une justice qui est là pour les punir. Nous, on est là pour travailler sur certains processus comme sur la récidive.
On n'est pas là pour en rajouter une couche. C'est pas, ce n'est pas notre boulot. On a choisi de faire un métier qui n'est pas celui de punir les gens.
On doit bien savoir dans quel cadre on intervient et d'utiliser les outils les plus professionnels possible. Ça, c'est-- j'espère avoir fait passer ce message-là aujourd'hui.
Mais je pense que tout ça était très clair. Vous vous êtes très bien exprimé sur toutes ces notions. Pour ceux et celles qui veulent vous suivre, donc, on disait, vous avez un podcast, Psyké.
Exactement, Psyké, ouais.
Donc c'est toutes les deux semaines, c'est ça ?
C'est toutes les deux semaines. Alors, on vient ici pendant une année d'en enregistrer pas mal et on reprendra d'ici quelques semaines avec tout- Plein de surprises en plus donc restez à l'écoute.
Ah, vous faites ça bien. Mais donc vous ne pouvez pas, vous ne pouvez pas déjà nous dire les sujets sur lesquels vous, vous espérez réaliser des biopics puisque donc c'est surtout votre confrère qui vient à vous avec des--
c'est surtout lui qui organise tout ce qui passe.
Alors ouais, mon collègue et, et qui est par ailleurs mon directeur a plein, plein de, de bonnes idées dans sa besace et on est, on est en train effectivement de, de réfléchir à un format un tout petit peu différent dans les semaines qui viennent et,
et donc bah voilà, restez à l'écoute et allez voir sur Psyké assez fréquemment, des nouvelles fraîches seront bientôt disponibles.
Des nouvelles fraîches ?
Ouais.
Incroyable. Mais écoutez, je mettrai en tout cas le lien vers Psyké en description-
Ah, c'est gentil. Un grand merci.
Dans ce podcast. Et donc par ailleurs, vous êtes très actif sur LinkedIn pour ceux que, pour ceux qui sont sur LinkedIn.
D'autres endroits où on peut vous lire ou suivre ?
Non non, j'ai, j'ai choisi effectivement un réseau social qui correspond à mon âge, donc je suis plutôt sur, sur LinkedIn. Voilà.
Ça se voyait tellement dans la façon dont je l'ai dit ou qu'est-ce que...
Bah oui, un petit peu. Mais puis on ne peut pas tout faire non plus. Non non,
si, si des personnes sont éventuellement intéressées, qu'ils n'hésitent pas à taper mon nom sur LinkedIn et en général, je centralise un petit peu mes activités sur ce réseau social.
Super. Écoutez Pierre, merci beaucoup pour ce, ce-
Un grand merci à vous.
On se retrouve en septembre pour un prochain épisode. À très bientôt, au revoir. J'espère que mon entretien avec Pierre vous a plu.
Je vous rappelle qu'il a également un podcast, Psyké, que je vous encourage à aller écouter. C'est du travail très propre et j'ai mis un lien en description.
Voilà, c'était donc le dernier épisode de cette saison. Je sais, c'est triste, en particulier quand on sait qu'il y a eu énormément de trous dans cette saison et que voilà, pas énormément d'épisodes.
Mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que premièrement, je vous ferai un épisode bonus en solo dans les semaines qui vont suivre.
Un petit, un petit édito, c'est devenu un peu une tradition à ce stade hein.
Je risque de parler de changements que je compte mettre en place dans la production de Septante Minutes Avec, avec l'utilisation d'intelligence artificielle notamment, et parler plus globalement des, des nouveautés qui sont prévues.
Il y en a plusieurs avec, attention, le fait que je travaille maintenant avec un monteur, ce qui devrait beaucoup aider, beaucoup accélérer la, l'apparition des épisodes.
Je vous dis donc à très bientôt. On se retrouve dans quelques semaines et puis début septembre pour de nouvelles interviews.
Gros bisous et surtout, prenez soin de vous.